[Musique]
il y a quand même un fossé très agaçant
entre une madame l'oiseau qui n'assume
pas son passé et une madame l'oiseau qui
fait des leçons de morale à tout le
monde de lui qu'elle est entrée en
campagne
un peu de modestie voire gérard lâché
hervé morin laurent wauquiez
françois-xavier bellamy sur la même
tribune hier c'est la preuve que l'unité
de la droite et du centre a non
seulement possible mais elle est en
mouvement aujourd'hui politique un
programme concret pragmatique au service
de la france au service des français
pour refonder leur ont refondé l'europe
rétablir la france refonder l'europe
parce qu'on a besoin de repenser en
profondeur le projet européen qui s'est
enlisé dans une forme de naïveté qui
fait notre impuissance aujourd'hui dans
la mondialisation
sur le plan économique et commercial
face au défi migratoire face à la crise
écologique il faut repenser la manière
dont l'europe se construit pour qu'elle
soit vraiment au service de notre
renforcement dans la mondialisation bien
ce que j'aimerais qu'on ait en commun
c'est cette capacité de dire à la fois
d'une même voix que l'objectif c'est
qu'il faut tout à la fois qu on
réaffirme ce qu'est l'identité de la
france etc on refonde l'europe nous
c'est ce que nous portons dans cette
campagne européenne bien éloignée
d'ailleurs de ce que sont les deux
discours qui sont pour moi 2 impasse
parce que je suis convaincu que ça et
c'est beaucoup plus important c'est le
consensus des français et celui là et qu
en plus
[Musique]
les français sont pas dupes et là on est
avant les élections donc on a les bonnes
nouvelles mais après qu'est ce qui se
passera ma crainte c'est que les cadeaux
d'aujourd'hui qui sont financés à coups
de déficits budgétaires
eh ben ça fasse les impôts de demain le
premier sentiment qui me vient en
regardant cette conférence de presser au
fond tout ça pour ça je vois pas le cap
je vois pas où le président va emmener
les français et ce que je vois c'est
beaucoup de zigzags beaucoup
d'inconstance
beaucoup de changements n'oubliez pas
une chose le coeur de la crise qu'on
affronte aujourd'hui c'était quoi quand
on est descendu tous les premiers au
contact des gilets jaunes
c'était pas le risque c'était pas la
haine anti-flic s'était pas tout ça
c'était monsieur le député je travaille
tous les jours et à la fin du mois je
n'arrive même plus à emmener mes enfants
au faso d'austin à mars pour leur faire
pour leur faire plaisir quand même six
mois une demi année où il ne se passe
plus rien le quinquennat est entré en
marche arrière depuis la crise et gilet
jaune gouvernement de gouverner plus
l'assemblée nationale est presque
suspendu